this episode is brought to you by Target
it may be too early to do an honest
trailer for the rise of Skywalker but
it's never too early to get honest so
here's our honest teaser for the trailer
for rise of Skywalker which makes this
an honest trailer for a trailer but it's
a teaser look we want to do a Star War
and the Mandalorians not done yet so
just enjoy it or don't epic voice guy
gets paid either way
Oh second new Jumanji I'm pretty sure
that's Endor and ours a deciduous forest
planet choice boys
solo bombed galaxy's edge is empty the
last Jedi was a complete cinematic
failure
[Music]
but we're not done baby Yoda is here if
we need him sad boys keep calling me a
MarySue like this one
I'm not sad debate
no have I waited even longer or not that
part there I am looking good chief
millennium falcon of course that's ghost
there's the crucible I believe that's
the shadow caster that's probably the
outrider as I was saying did I ever tell
you the tragedy of Darth Plagueis the
wise it's totally wizard wait don't go
what we're doing there are three bill
providing the red herring sir that I'm
going to die in this movie my country
returning as a ghost is the destiny of a
Jedi
[Music]
or I'm not really dead
or and brought back to life as a port
for time travel
maybe he'll meet Captain America
whatever before you decided whether
you're there like this better not screw
it we'll still take your money
always
[Music]
sorry I'm late am I in this no all right
then who's the best choice to blow up a
galaxy far far away Thanos or the Death
Star
we made scientists analyze footage to
give you the definitive answer in an
all-new episode of power levels but be
warned Thanos will have to take a dump
at some point click here to watch now
and make your physics teacher proud this
holiday the toys of a generation of Star
Wars fans come home explore a whole
galaxy of Star Wars toys available at
Target you don't have to request Marvel
movies we're going to do Marvel movies
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30
days